so one of the things that makes Nayak
specialists are insane attention to
detail
[Music]
and that comes from just extreme amount
of research so whether it's researching
of theme let's say this this idea of
retribution or justice like we would
read a ton of books and look at movies
and even watch like interviews and news
programs about stuff that's going on in
the world and then discuss it among
ourselves like what's happening here
what can we draw from this how can we
base these fictional characters on
reality to make them feel more
[Music]
I hope with this game is to create the
most authentic characters that you've
seen in a game not just le not just Joel
but that every character you see is
dimensional obviously in telling a
character-driven story you have to
create characters and it starts with a
story concept that then can develop into
level ideas and more specific narrative
beats once we kind of have a good
understanding of the narrative that
we're after we could start writing
scripts and that's really the first time
the characters come to life and they're
speaking even though it's just words on
the page
now they're becoming more specific and
the next step after that is to either
bring in the existing cast from the
first game such as Ashley Johnson who
played Ellie and Troy Baker who played
Joel or casting new characters and
they're interpreting the material and
bringing their knowledge of these
characters and their take on these
characters to life
I think authenticity from every
department has been kind of a goal or a
focus whether or not that's in the
animations and how we're mo capping or
in the effects and how we're simulating
you know the different elements to get
the effect look that we want in game we
wanted it to be as realistic as possible
as believable as possible so that as
you're playing you can hopefully get
fully invested in it and fully immersed
and we didn't want to have a character
moment where it's unbelievable both from
a narrative and visual standpoint some
other events that we've had is like now
we can like make veins pop on their
forehead it's like they're really angry
or likewise there's we can redden their
skin it could be based on the motion or
it could be based on what's happening to
them physically
how read their eyes can get this
controllable how tears flow off their
eyes in their face is all new tech them
we've developed for this game girl did
you see additionally we have this human
nuance to our human enemies that makes
the situations that you're in so much
more terrifying and emotionally
affecting than they would be otherwise
because at almost every turn we've gone
as far as we possibly can go to make our
human enemies feel as human as possible
I got something you can hear the enemy
is calling out looking for you and
giving you slight little gameplay hints
as to what they're gonna do and so you
can try to plan around it we got
something I'll go see what's up so
whether that's the nuance of their
awareness systems like what they should
know about and when how they convey
knowledge to their friends to the kind
of emotional content of the game so when
they refer to each other by name when
they scream and anguish when they see
their friend die
when they they scream in anger as
they're like kind of trying to hunt you
down or attack you they feel real and it
makes the situation that you're in feel
real in a way that you haven't seen
before and you might not be ready for
[Music]
there was a ton of research that was
done into foliage and different kind of
foliage that existed in different parts
of the country to make those areas feel
authentic studying local architecture of
wherever we are and making sure that
feels authentic we took three trips up
to Seattle we actually got photos scan
data of like natural elements and the
forests and went through and walked the
path of alley through Seattle to
actually get as much reference that we
could and that was anything from going
you know inside buildings and taking
pictures of signs on the wall to various
bus stops and awnings around the world
like we're trying to find those kind of
iconic details and bring them into the
environment that once we get it into the
final game it's like it all comes
together to hopefully make something as
believable as we can hopefully with all
these things combined it it gives you
the feeling that you're playing at
Naughty Dog game this is what we go for
I feel like these are all real people I
feel like this is a real place I feel
like this was a real situation that I
was in and I handled it in a way that
makes sense if this was real life
[Music]
please